charlotte gainsbourg léa seydoux ou plus
récemment boucle une bécane zoe kravitz
les enfants de will smith et gabriel
kane day-lewis
le sociologue pierre bourdieu les a
faites désir itier les médias eux disent
fils ou filles 2 comment on les
reconnaît facile à peine nés ils savent
jouer chanter et connaissent déjà leur
meilleur profil est aujourd'hui celle à
qui tout réussit c'est lily rose dead en
son compte oui un 19 ans l'héritière de
vanessa paradis et johnny depp et déjà
comme papa et maman
un vrai concentré de signer mode et
beauté
elle a vraiment un côté rebelle rock en
même temps un visage faussement lisse
qui en plus de la fashion week
illuminera le 23 janvier le film les
fauves dame arrive en corner je sens les
ventes ok alors que se cache-t-il
derrière ce regard énigmatique
jha a voulu revenir sur l'itinéraire de
cette héritière qui aime cultiver le
mystère
[Musique]
c'est le 27 mai 1999 que vanessa paradis
et johnny depp
alors le couple le plus cool et glamour
d'hollywood donne naissance à la petite
lily rose melody à l'hôpital américain
de neuilly à la base elle avait tout
pour être un enfant sur exposé parce
qu'il y avait énormément de curiosité
autour de sa naissance et donc on a
appris que par exemple à la maternité y
avait carrément n'est pas paradis
habillant malade pour pouvoir prendre
des photos d'elle vv aucune photo ne
filtrera et comme un bonheur n'arrive
jamais seul la même année johnny reçoit
dans la foulée un césar d'honneur
je vous remercie je ne comprends pas
vraiment le concept des prix en général
et je déteste l'idée de compétition
le seul contre lequel je me bats chez
moi pour aller plus loin chaque fois
dans mon travail et inaugure sur
hollywood boulevard son étoile
[Musique]
très vite les parents rock troque les
clubs contre des couches culottes et
pour protéger leur ligne est leur devise
devient pour vivre heureux vivons cachés
elle les parents ont décidé de fermer
les rideaux et de la halakha chez elle
et son frère les projecteurs mais à 13
ans la lolita 2.0 le voit autrement et
en parfaite ados se mettent à dévoiler
un peu de sa vie sur les réseaux sociaux
dès lors vanessa préfère prendre les
devants quand même relevé le fait que sa
mère a tellement bien orchestré la
première sortie publique de sa fille
printemps 2015
un défilé chanel à new york se
transforme en première sortie officielle
c'était très très fort la part de
vanessa paradis pour comme cultiver
cette image de sophistication et
d'élégance et ce jour-là à 15 ans non
seulement elle tape dans l'oeil de karl
lagerfeld devenant 25 ans après sa mère
[Musique]
la plus jeune égérie d'un célèbre parfum
mais elle retient également l'attention
de nathalie portman qui souffle son nom
à rebecca zlotowski la réalisatrice de
planétarium dedans elle incarne deux
soeurs des années 30 capable de
communiquer avec les morts
j'aime les personnages comme ça qui sont
pas forcément les plus bruyants mais le
fait d'être dans sa niche change quelque
chose
c'est ça que j'aime c'est dans la foulée
lily rose enchaîne avec la danseuse et
se frotte à d'autres partenaires
confirmés comme gaspard ulliel mélanie
thierry et soco qu'elle a complètement
envoûté le résultat une première montée
des marches à cannes et une nomination
2017 au césar de meilleur espoir
lily rose 17 ans est enfin reconnue pour
autre chose que ses parents ce que je
fais j'espère que si ça c'est la nature
de la curiosité a changé alors ça fait
très bien mais alors qu'on s'attendait à
la voir squatter l'écran lily rose
préfère cultiver l'art ainsi au ciné on
lui offre beaucoup beaucoup de rôles
mais l'on prend très peu elle est
extrêmement sélective et elle fait des
choix intelligents parce qu'elle m'a pas
non plus trop au devant de la scène et
elle choisit des auteurs 2018 quelques
couvertures de magazines plus tard lily
actrice sort enfin de son silence avec
l'homme fidèle de louis garrel le film
raconte un triangle amoureux entre abel
marianne et eve et offre surtout à lily
rose un rôle sur mesure dans le
personnage dans le film à 18 ans elle
avait 18 ans quand elle a fait le film
et le savez c'est ce moment assez
miraculeuse est une actrice a exactement
le même âge que le personnage du coup ce
qu'elle donne au personnage correspond
un truc très intime
je suis de parler de mythes
oui tu veux qu'on prenne un thé ou un
café non non non j'en ai dit écoute je
vais dire quelque chose
oui quoi
tu voudrais a bel et bon ça c'est sûr
que je me suis reconnu là dedans et puis
surtout aussi dans de ce sentiment de
dire tout d'un coup je suis femme je
peux avoir toutes ces choses là pendant
j'ai pu me rendre fantasmer je peux les
avoir un film qui prépare le terrain aux
fauves en salles le 23 janvier prochain
un thriller à la limite du fantastique
dans lequel on ne l'attendait pas et
encore moins en tête d'affiche un
paradoxe pour l'actrice qui en pleine
lumière entretient toujours sa part de
secret tu joues
on la connaît pas vraiment complètement
malgré le fait qu'elle soit sur les
réseaux
malgré le fait que on connaît ses
parents qu'elle soit l'égérie chanel etc
elle cultive quand même ce côté
mystérieux et donc ça serait intéressant
de la voir dans ce rôle voilà si lily
rose d'eps n'arrête pas de retourner à l
est le cinéma français lui n'arrête pas
de la rappeler quelques reconnaissances
que ce soit ça ça fait sa fête et non
les ja et près de 30 ans après le césar
de vanessa pour noces blanches elles
pourraient bien lui emboîter le pas